bonjour abdelaziz ben dhia merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
j'imagine que vous avez entendu
aujourd'hui le discours d' emmanuel
macron qu'est ce que vous retenez ces
annonces
oui dans l'ensemble des déclarations du
président de la république nous sommes
assez satisfaits mais nous ne sommes pas
tu donc comme à chaque élection
présidentielle approche des élections
présidentielles donc la prison la
république lance une opération de
séduction en direction des indépendants
qui représentent près de 3 millions de
commerçants d'artisans de profession des
draps et nous savons très bien que
c'est une opération qui vise à séduire
les commerçants qui subissons une crise
sociale sans précédent une crise
économique depuis plusieurs années qui
est venu s'ajouter à la crise sanitaire
qui nous prive de du parti de mon
chiffre d'affaires faut savoir que ce
chiffre d'affaires des commerçants des
marchés de france a considérablement
chuté et nous sommes en très grosse
difficultés et cette proposition cette
annonce du président république est la
bienvenue notamment sur les différents
dispositifs notamment l'instabilité des
biens cancale faillite la réduction de
la réduction des cotisations cotisations
qui pèsent très lourd donc sur notre
chiffre d'affaires actuellement depuis
quelques années en plus et j'en profite
aussi pour alerter on a dû re sable qui
nous avancer un retour un rappel de
cotisation donc c'est très difficile
beaucoup de nos collègues ont dû déposer
le bilan ont dû faire faillite ils n'ont
pas bénéficié des mesures énoncées par
tous dans la rue crient ils ont été déjà
des gens qui n'avaient pas bien donc ils
ont été saisis et leurs comptes été
saisis ils ont été dans l'obligation de
solder leurs comptes est et c'est pour
eux très difficile et pour nous cette
mesure tombe à point nommé on espère que
ça sera pas le même effet d'annonce qui
a été fait lors des dernières
présidentielles
lorsque le présent république a supprimé
les récits pour créer une sécurité
sociale
des indépendants affiliés à la sécurité
sociale g ral avec les mêmes conditions
donc absolument pas changé macron a
changé le nom des récits mais c'est
toujours le même dispositif et c'est
toujours quand même très difficile pour
nous donc on espère que ces propositions
donc sur vos boîtes et parce qu'elles
seront soumis prochainement à un vote du
parlement on espère qu'elles seront
votés on espère que le prix de vente
public viendra notre écoute nous les
commerçants des marchés comme il s'est
rendu avec deux paires à la mutualité
aujourd'hui j'espère qu'on sera entendue
et écoutée on souffre on s'ouvre sur les
marchés un peu partout par france et on
a vraiment besoin d'un coup de pouce du
président atypique et d'en
rencontrer les résidents de la
république vous vous vous espérer qu'il
sera attentif à vos amours de
revendications qu est ce que vous
pourriez lui demander concrètement au
président de la république et si vous le
rencontriez demain
lui déjà ce qu'on pourra lui
les quotidiens du groupe calculé chez
vous savez on a des collègues ou ont pas
ils espèrent parfois comme pendant la
période du copil on a payé pour plus de
cotisations notre chiffre d'affaires est
poussé par matt de nos collègues qu'on
souhaite également qu'on voit la salle
écoute on souhaite également par rapport
ce qui concerne la crise sanitaire on
nous impose en impose à nos clients à
lacaune et en plein air sur les marchés
on impose le masque alors que le mas
n'est plus obligatoire en extérieur il
est obligatoire sur les marchés au mou
on souhaite on sollicite le présenter à
un public que le port du bas ce ne soit
plus obligatoire sur les marchés et qui
lui ce flicage constante
des policiers municipaux sur le marché
l'assouplissement hostile également de
tout ce qui est cotisations sociales
cotisations vieillesse et la paix dans
la répudier qui a parlé cet après midi à
la mutualité
l'assouplissement les conditions pour
l'assurance-chômage savoir que nous
servons au film en une assurance chômage
nous demandons être appuyée mais aussi à
l'assurance chômage nous demandons aussi
être considérée comme toutes les autres
professions le jour où ça va pas le jour
où on se ou obligés de déposer le bilan
qu'on puisse se retrouver avec un
certain revenu ce qui n'est pas le cas
ce qui est très utile sur un chômage les
expos mediène dont ada par les manuels
macron aujourd'hui lors de lors de ces
annonces merci abdelaziz boumédiène
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association des
commerçants indépendants des marchés de
france merci beaucoup